>> Jedediah: WELCOME BACK.
DISGRACED CELEBRITY LAWYER
MICHAEL AVENATTI FACING NEARLY
100 YEARS BEHIND BARS FOR
ALLEGEDLY ATTEMPTING TO EXTORT
MILLIONS FROM NIKE AND FOR A
WIRE AND FRAUD CASE OUT OF
CALIFORNIA.
HERE'S HOW HE'S FEELING ABOUT
IT.
>> WHAT I WILL SAY IS THE WAY
THIS HAS BEEN FRAMED IS NOT
ACCURATE.
IT'S JUST NOT ACCURATE.
>> YOU'RE FACING IF CONVICTED ON
ALL THESE CHARGES, UP TO THE
REST OF YOUR LIFE IN PRISON.
ARE YOU NERVOUS?
>> OF COURSE I'M NERVOUS.
>> ARE YOU SCARED?
ARE YOU CONCERNED?
TELL US, AS SOMEONE WHO AGAIN
HAS A HISTORY OF OUR PRESENT AND
PEOPLE AND NOW YOU'RE ON THE
OTHER SIDE FACING SOME SERIOUS
CHARGES.
>> I AM NERVOUS.
I'M CONCERNED.
I'M SCARED.
>> Jedediah: WOW, QUITE A FALL
FROM GRACE FOR THIS GUY.
>> Greg: WHAT GRACE?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jedediah: PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT HIM LIKE HE WAS A
SERIOUS 2020 CONTENDER.
HE GOT A LOT OF AIR TIME, THIS
GUY, NO REASON THIS POSITION.
>> Jesse: HE'S A CLASSIC
SHAKEDOWN ARTIST, SCAM ARTIST,
SHARK.
HE NEEDED THIS WAIL OF NIKE, THE
$20 MILLION PAYOUT TO KEEP THE
HOUSE OF CARDS FROM FALLING DOWN
ON HIM.
HE'S LIKE, HE'S GOT THE
CHARACTER OF JUSSIE SMOLLETT
WITH THE TASTE OF PAUL MANAFORT.
WHILE HE WAS ESCORTING THESE
TAXES FOR TEN YEARS, HE SPENT
$200,000 AT NEIMAN MARCUS,
$270,000 AT PORSCHE DEALERSHIPS.
$100,000 A MONTH RENT FOR A
HOUSE IN NEWPORT BEACH, AND 40
GRAND FOR FERRARI LEASE
PAYMENTS.
HE WAS STEALING FROM CLIENTS,
STIFFING HIS OWN EMPLOYEES.
THE IRS HAS BEEN GOING AFTER
THEM FOR TEN YEARS.
HE'S FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY
PROTECTION TWICE.
THIS WHOLE TIME, US HERE HAVE
SAID I KNOW THIS GUY IS A PHONY.
YOU KNOW WHY?
WE HAVE STREET SMARTS.
CNN, THEY MIGHT HAVE BOOK
SMARTS.
WE HAVE STREET SMARTS.
>> Dana: WE HAVE STREET AND
BOOK SMARTS.
>> Jesse: YOU DO.
WE CAN SMELL A PHONY FROM A MILE
AWAY AND EVERYONE ELSE BOUGHT
THIS GUY HOOK, LINE, AND SINKER.
>> Jedediah: SO UP NOXIOUS AND
SO FULL OF HIMSELF, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU REALIZES WHAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HAPPEN.
>> Greg: IT'S A SHAME HE
WASN'T ARRESTED IN CHICAGO.
HE WOULD GET A WEEK OF COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
I'M SORRY.
LET'S REWIND.
I WILL ERASE IT.
THE MEDIA MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT GAVE HIM
THE SPOTLIGHT.
YOU KNOW IS HAVING A NICE TALL
BEER RIGHT NOW?
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
JUSTICE MAY BE SLOW BUT IN THIS
CASE IT'S TAKING THE CORRECT
COURSE.
THIS IS A GUY.
IF YOU FEEL ANY PANGS OF
SYMPATHY FOR THIS LITIGATING
LOLLIPOP, REMEMBER WHAT HE TRIED
TO DO TO KAVANAUGH.
I THINK A LOT OF DEMOCRATS WERE
MAD BECAUSE HE TRIED TO DO A
BETTER JOB AT THE PUBLIC
HANGING.
>> Jesse: JUAN SAID YESTERDAY
THAT THE AVENATTI ALLEGATIONS
HELPED KAVANAUGH.
>> Greg: IT MIGHT HAVE.
>> Jesse: , ON.
>> Greg: IT WAS HORRIBLE.
>> Jesse: SERIAL GANG RAPIST
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
>> Juan: THE FACT THAT IT CAME
UP EMPTY HELPED KAVANAUGH.
EVERYONE WAS PILING ON.
I AM NOTING THAT KAVANAUGH,
SOMETHING APART FROM KAVANAUGH,
WHICH IS TRUMP AND STORMY
DANIELS.
PEOPLE ARE SEEING THIS HAS A
PAYBACK ON AVENATTI.
I THINK AVENATTI IS INTERESTING
TO ME THAT HE SAYS HE'S JUST AN
AGGRESSIVE ATTORNEY.
AGGRESSIVE ATTORNEY?
HE SAID IT'S NOT EXTORTION OF
NIKE, THAT HE WAS ENGAGED IN
THREATENING THEM.
PEOPLE DO THAT ALL THE TIME IN
TERMS OF SETTLEMENTS.
I THINK HE'S GOT A TWISTED VIEW
OF HOW YOU ARE AN AGGRESSIVE
ATTORNEY.
IT'S GONE OVER THE LINE.
HE MAY NOT KNOW IT.
HE SHOULD BE SCARED BECAUSE HE
MAY BE GOING TO FACE REAL JAIL
TIME.
YESTERDAY ON THE SHOW HE SAID
WITH THE TWO DIFFERENT, ONE IN
L.A. AND THIS ONE.
100 YEARS IN JAIL.
>> Dana: WE WILL BE HAPPY TO
PAY HIS RENT FOR HIM IF HE'S IN
PRISON FOR 100 YEARS.
I WAS GOING TO SAY THAT AVENATTI
NEEDS SMOLLETT'S LAWYERS.
>> Greg: HOW CAN HE NOT PAY
TAXES?
HOW DO PEOPLE NOT PAY TAXES?
>> Jesse: GREG, $56 MILLION